hey guys out the guy gets 15 and today's
unboxing is a little bit different than
usual today we are unboxing something
vintage this is the original iPod
shuffle
[Music]
I want to be what it first came out the
irony of the few days before they
announced the discontinuation of the
current gen iPod shuffle and I find
Daniel my friend and I were chatting
about fit the first-ever iPod shuffle I
found a bunch of them on eBay nobody
really wanted them or cared they were
super cheese or even some that had never
been opened
at least that's what it says so I've
been on this two days later Apple
announcement they've just continued the
iPod shuffles and iPod nanos and the
prices skyrocketed so go figure at least
I got in there two days before but it
didn't really matter because that point
people were still bidding on this one
long story short I've got it
don't cross the fingers and hope that
this is actually what they said it was
Oh guys so far so good
it looks actually to be legit sealed now
this could easily be fake as we all know
as you can see right here it says iPod
shuffle 512 megabytes designed by Apple
in California assembled in China 2005
Apple Computer all rights reserved to
take a really good look at this box
what's the shuffle your favorite songs
in a different order every time Y
shuffle sometimes it's good to mix
things up I thought shuffle your music
is never the same experience choice I
feel like this is just sort of a basic
excuse we're basically going to take
this little flash drive and make it play
music and sell it and you're going to
buy it and everyone's going to love it
how does it know it's song to play next
can it read your mind
can it read your moves load it up put it
on and see where it takes you a hundred
and twenty songs a million different
ways I don't want to open it cuz it's
beautiful it's brand-new this has never
been touched by any other human since
what 2005 we're going to do this we're
going to cut it open this is so exciting
oh yeah this looks brand-new and I'm
super excited about it
take a look in there looks new to me
I'm so excited about this
look at this accessible packaging oh
[Music]
that was surprising I didn't realize
like a pool tab I thought this whole
thing was going to come up so that's an
interesting design choice you've got
this little thing that you can like tie
around your neck so you can wear your
shuffle of the necklace got our shuffle
we've got our headphones look at that
3.5 millimeter jack what we have here
damage anything because it's very very
precious wow I didn't damage it what I
did Oh show Oh show
don't steal music all right with a
little car that shows us how to use our
iPod shuffle you've also got some things
here on the back that you have to check
the batteries the batteries charging and
what the lights mean okay this is
something I haven't seen in a really
long time
we also have a CD in case we want to
install itunes what free music for my
ipod yes please every week and get a
free single of the week you guys
remember one that was the thing do they
still do that and one-year warranty I
think my warranty might be up let's all
back in here all I destroy it and look
at you party this is something you guys
have never seen before I'm going to look
so cool with my shuffle pop this out
take a good look at this thing here's
the front obviously the controls are
quite self-explanatory and if you
haven't seen one of these by now and I'm
not really sure what to say to you
perhaps it's because you were born after
this came out which is also a very very
possible thing still software for
connecting iPod and that just pops off
just like that it's basically just a
strive if that would assess 512 megs now
to get this to work to to wear it like a
necklace you just remove the top of it
and then you use that clip on okay I'm
so I'm definitely wearing this this is
my new fashion piece and if anybody has
anything that they want to say about it
you can come at I think this is going to
be my new look too many wearing I'm
wearing a vintage 2005 iPod shuffle I'm
definitely going to Fashion Week
here's a happy entire oh it's by vintage
Apple China around Oh mm oh you know
fashion because it's me me where should
I put this oh my god I'm beautiful this
is true beauty it hurt so beauty's pain
person said how the quilt bones do I
have anything else I can wear or
provided hit rock bottom
some people say well justine you're not
well in a really great or not well this
is my look I think it's really excited
about it and I hope that you are just as
excited about my look as I am now I need
to see if this iPod shuffle dish will
work this is this is what we're here for
to see if this will work but this light
is on to pass good news that means it's
actually working
but will this recognize it not working
so well yet tried this one will not
showing up in iTunes or any way to sync
it so I'm not sure I think I'm just
going to let it charge for a while and
maybe try and get another day but I am
super excited about my purchase because
I think it's going to look so good when
I wear this thing out at a date tonight
Oh wearing my finest iPod shuffle thank
you guys so much for watching hope you
guys enjoyed this I am so excited to try
to get this to work in a future video
and even if I don't get it to work it is
now a fashion accessory make me some
comments below because anything else
really cool that you'd like me to check
out especially if there is a fun vintage
Apple product I will try to get it and
do it uh nothing the way I'm still
excited
just actually had it been opened before
so exciting I'll see you guys in my next
video bye
[Music]
doodle-do